[Música]
y llegamos a madrid ahí está nuestra
corresponsal de marina colorado porque
se vive la peor ola de calor antes del
inicio del verano en estos últimos 20
años se espera que las temperaturas
alcancen un pico entre hoy y mañana
marín a la salud o muy buena tarde le
pregunto cómo está la situación en el
país y por supuesto en la capital
española madrid 'la está haciendo honor
a su apellido hasta color ajá marina de
tanto calor hay en madrid
si es que 15 de las 17 comunidades
autónomas que es como le llamamos en
españa a las regiones o departamentos
están por aviso de altas temperaturas
siete de ellas con alerta naranja entre
ellas madrid andalucía y cataluña por
temperaturas que podrían alcanzar los 43
grados unos termómetros entre 5 y 10
grados por encima de la media para esta
época del año que tan solo estamos a
mediados de julio se espera como bien
decías que los días más calurosos sean
hoy para el sur de la península y mañana
para el resto del país donde se podrían
alcanzar los 45 grados celsius por lo
pronto ahora en madrid son casi las 3 de
la tarde y estamos más o menos alrededor
de los 37 grados pero se espera que a
las 7 de la tarde que es la hora más
calurosa del día aquí en madrid se
puedan alcanzar los 39 grados y medio de
temperatura algunas de las de las
medidas que ha impuesto el ayuntamiento
de madrid- para proteger a los
ciudadanos es cerrar parques infantiles
que no estén protegidos por árboles o
por sombra o acotar algunas zonas
públicas para que la gente no vaya y no
se exponga al sol una recomendación que
han hecho porque además el índice v está
el número 11 que es el más alto
extremadamente alto y también como
pueden ver detrás de mí después de dos
años cerrados por la pandemia de kobe 19
el ayuntamiento de madrid ha vuelto a
abrir estas fuentes que los madrileños
conocemos como la playa de madrid porque
como bien saben madrid está en el centro
del país no tenemos playas naturales así
que esto es lo más cercano a una playa
que podamos tener en madrid y la han
abierto para que la ciudadanos puedan
refrescarse en estos lugares así esa
marina por lo menos también está
haciendo un poco de brisa no para pues
aliviar un poco este calor pero es que
también la agencia estatal de
metereología de españa ha alertado que
esta quizás sea la primera ola de calor
en el año la primera es decir que pueden
venir muchas más y aún ni siquiera ha
comenzado el verano
exacto es que quedan siete días para que
oficialmente entre la época veraniega en
el hemisferio norte el 21 de junio pero
las temperaturas veraniegas como bien
hemos podido comprobar desde hace desde
mayo de hecho en españa están aquí y
están aquí para quedarse todavía lo que
no sabe la agencia estatal de
metereología es si realmente lo será la
ola de calor porque para que eso suceda
para que sea una ola de calor tiene que
cumplirse tres requisitos intensidad
extensión y duración intensidad pues que
las temperaturas sean más altas que la
media de temperaturas en julio y agosto
que son los meses más calurosos
normalmente del verano en esta región de
lo que han sido en los últimos años
desde
1971 extensión pues que es la mayor
parte del país se vea afectada y
duración que dure mínimo tres días
consecutivos por ahora la agencia
estatal de metereología dice que la ola
de calor durará o este episodio de calor
por confirmar todavía si es ola de calor
durará hasta el viernes así que todos
los ingredientes parecen estar ahí para
como bien decías tú sea la peor ola de
calor en junio que es el inicio del
verano en los últimos 20 años y es que
precisamente esta agencia dice que estos
fenómenos en junio se han hecho cinco
veces más frecuentes en lo que llevamos
de siglo es decir en los últimos 22 años
un cambio y un aumento de temperaturas
que han atribuido al cambio climático
que como bien sabemos y como bien hemos
estado informando durante los últimos
años en france24 en español hace que
estos episodios de temperaturas extremas
ya sea hacia el frío o hacia el calor
sean más intensas y más frecuentes y
aunque a veces tendemos a mostrar las
imágenes más amables de estas olas de
calor como por ejemplo niños bañándose
en fuentes o personas refrescándose en
la playa hay que recordar que estos
eventos son muy peligrosos para la salud
sobre todo de los más vulnerables por
eso hay tantas recomendaciones de
mantenerse a la sombra hidratarse y
recordar que en el 2003 en el año 2003
unas 35.000 personas murieron en europa
en la ola de calor que hubo entre ellas
seis mil en españa' así que más nos vale
tomarnos en serio estos episodios que
como decíamos van a ser cada vez más
intensos y más frecuentes así es marina
como siempre muchísimas gracias por su
reporte desde la capital española